so take me back you said that you
bankrolled anita uh baker's first record
mm-hmm
so how did because you know obviously in
your position you have a lot of money
that you need to put places and you need
to yeah i was looking for i was looking
for legitimate businesses things that
get me out of the dope game of course i
i didn't want to be in the dope game
so how
how does this anita baker story happen
because i mean obviously you told us you
linked with uh you just said his name
i'm sorry older smith photo smith when i
was in high school
and and another mistake i made not being
young you know not really understanding
business at the time i was a tennis
player
okay oda smith had a son
that he wanted to be a professional
tennis player
his son was about three years younger
than me so oldest would come pick me up
from high school
would pay me 20 dollars
for me and at that time that was a lot
of money yeah 20 bucks back then i mean
20 bucks in the 90s was lit buy me
tennis shoes we buy me rackets to go and
play with his son i played with his son
just about every day wow after school i
would finish at the tennis team do my
little tennis practice at the school and
then he would pick me up we'd go to
beverly hills hollywood uh it was
another place where kennedy got killed
at it used to be a tennis club really
nice tennis club he he he was a few
tennis clubs he was the only black
that went there nobody else l.a tennis
club in hollywood he was the only member
for the longest there was no other black
member beside older smith in that club
so he would take me to those places and
and i would play with his son you know
hour hour and 20 minutes whatever
whatever time it took us to play a
couple sets
so
i grew up though after i was 16 17 i
think 17-18 i stopped playing with him i
dropped out of high school
and and went back to the streets so we
hadn't saw each other for years and all
this is in my book if you you get a
chance yeah your book's been out for a
while too it's been about five years
yeah it's been out for me but they still
don't know why you know about it yeah
it's still kind of like unknown you know
we're still buying it on amazon i'm sure
don't go to amazon and get it don't go
no where should they go go to freeway
ricky ross and get my book buy the book
there that way you can get it
autographed you get it autographed and
you get to keep all the money
you don't got to give amazon their cut
yeah i don't want to get jeff piso
nothing he's got enough i'm hating on
jeff yeah for sure
rich [ __ ] go to space so uh
um i loved otis
let me say that there yeah so one day
i'm just like chilling out right here in
santa monica it was a professional
tennis tournament going on
and i ain't seen notice in five six
years you know i got hair on my face now
i'm a grown man getting money i ain't 16
no more and i got about two three
million dollars cash
and i'm at the tennis court i'm by
myself you know no no homies don't want
to go to no tennis match and i just kick
back on the bench and got my hand got my
cell phone and you know just relaxing
this is a relaxed day
and then i look up there was little
oldest
nice like six feet three and
hit his son his son yeah hitting the
ball a ton
and he's playing against the number one
guy from stanford
big guy looks like a linebacker
and they start arguing
and then the guy from stanford the whole
team is backing him mm-hmm
otis he's playing at ucla the only black
guy on the team right
nobody backing him
he's by himself
i said man
i better get some help so i got on the
phone i called all the guys i was like
man some some white boys finna jump on
me out here in santa monica come at boo
you know they was in l.a we in santa
monica was in like five minutes i heard
motorcycles tire screeching and it's a
hell of a that's a hell of a time to
get that far as soon as they come
the kid who who little oldest is arguing
with hit the daddy in the eye bam
and then my guy's just coming over the
fence i see him coming over the fence
and they looking at me like
he do that
and and they don't even know all this
but they just know it's a black guy and
a white guy fighting so and then i just
gave him the nod and and they wouldn't
handle their business so
um when they broke it all i wouldn't
broke it all up kind of when none of my
guys went to jail so that relationship
kept it started all over again it
started all over in that day
so otis don't even know that i did that
for him
right like he don't know who what
happened he just know man damn somebody
saved my life because he was trying to
get mastercard i can imagine so uh then
the tennis coach my high school tennis
coach comes up he's the one that
introduced me to oldest
because he knew i needed money in high
school so
uh they started talking and i'm just
standing back to the side listening you
know glad to see my old coach again you
know
because my coach was nice to me you know
he he he helped me out a lot in life um
so i would start telling him about the
music business because i never knew i
just knew oldest drove a brand new rolls
royce convertible you know in the 70s
like right i don't know what you do you
know i don't even care what you do right
just keep giving me them 20s
so
he was talking to coach smith about the
music business and he was like man rick
is the one that uh you should be talking
to he got more money than sin
and and uh
he oh this looked at me and he was
trying to figure out did he know me
he's like little rick man
he's like little rick
he was like yeah so then i came over we
shook hands and he's like man it's been
a long time i'm gonna take you out for
dinner
and uh then the coach said he probably
won't say your life out here
so the relationship started the next day
he took me up to his office you know
showed me all the plaques you know
johnny taylor right he found rick james
you know uh his listen he just he was
just decorated
so i was already dipping in hip-hop
right then
you know i was messing with some local
rappers here and i had i had some
rappers from chicago i'd already sent
four that eventually signed with russell
simmons
what was your names
six-pack or something like that there
they didn't get big right okay
you know they got a little mediocre yeah
local you know local celebrities
so
um
oda started talking to me about this
girl
that he was going to produce
and he needed the money to produce her
he didn't even have the money to send
for i i gave him the money to send her
her ticket from detroit to come out here
and uh we got our apartment up in
hollywood hills and uh just started from
there i need a baker i need a bakery i
never got into the business though
you know i just gave him the money here
here's the money here's the money
so uh did you get a return on your
investment no
she jumped the label she oh okay okay
okay she jumped the label went to uh
i forgot the name of the label i paid
for the attorney to sue her oh wow